PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Welcome to "Get
Cooking in Cloud," where
we share the best recipes
to apply in your cloud kitchen.
I'm Priyanka, and
we're joined by Jenny.
JENNY BROWN: Hi, everyone.
Today we'll be
continuing our recipe
to help Dinner Winner make the
most of their implementation.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
And of course, we'll
be continuing with our
gluten-free recipe,
now that we have cleaned our
workspace of the identified
allergens.
JENNY BROWN: We've got a few
moving pieces with this recipe,
so let's quickly
review where we've been
and where we've got to go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
In the last episode,
we introduced the application
called Dinner Winner.
They collect recipes
from users all
over the world, review them,
and award prizes for the recipes
delicious enough to
repost on their app.
JENNY BROWN: The recipes aren't
supposed to, but they might
initially contain
personal information
of the participants, and that
information cannot make it
to the judging or the final
publicly-posted recipe card.
So there's some work to do
to make sure the automated
classification puts the
right data in the right spot
at the right time.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Fortunately, we've got a plan.
This will be a
four-step process.
Dinner Winner will first
create Cloud Storage Buckets
to be used as part
of the quarantine
and the classification pipeline.
They would need to
create a Cloud Pub/Sub
topic and subscription to
notify between the two Cloud
Functions.
Then they need to create
the two Cloud Functions, one
that invokes the DLP API
when files are uploaded,
and the second that uses the
DLP API to inspect and classify
the files and move them
to the appropriate bucket.
Then finally, upload some sample
files to the quarantine bucket
to invoke the Cloud Function.
JENNY BROWN: Now let's start
by creating the Cloud Storage
Bucket.
But before we can
even do that, we
need to set up our environment.
Create or select the GCP
project and make sure billing
is enabled.
Then head over to
the APIs and services
and enable APIs for Cloud
Functions, Cloud Storage,
and Cloud Data Loss
Prevention APIs.
Now that we have
the APIs enabled,
let's enable the
correct permissions
so that our App Engine
service account can
connect with the DLP API.
For that, we will open the IAM
& admin page in our project,
locate the App Engine service
account, and edit the roles.
Add project owner, DLP
administrator, and DLP API
service agent, and save.
Next, we'll grant the
DLP service account
the permission that it needs.
Locate the DLP API service agent
and add a project viewer's role
to it.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Now
we're ready to get our Cloud
Storage Buckets created.
We navigate to Cloud
Storage and create them.
Remember, we will need
three buckets, one
for sensitive data, one
for non-sensitive data,
and the last one for all
the files as they come in.
Name the buckets as
you wish, but remember,
it has to be a
globally unique name.
Once we have created
all three buckets,
you should be able to see them
all in the storage browser.
Now we are ready to set
up our Cloud Pub/Sub
topic and subscription.
Let's navigate to Cloud
Pub/Sub and create a topic,
provide it a name,
and hit Create.
Then to create a subscription
corresponding to the topic,
click on New Subscription,
provide it a name, and Create.
JENNY BROWN: At this point,
we've got the setup in place
for Dinner Winner and we
have two more steps left.
But now that we've
got our process
and our contaminant-free
environment, let's get baking.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
What a recipe.
This gluten-free
thing is no joke,
but it's critical to have an
understanding of what goes in
and what stays out.
JENNY BROWN: It's
a delicate balance,
but we're halfway there.
Stay tuned for next week when we
get Dinner Winner to the finish
line for their implementation.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Automated
classification, here we come.
For more information about
alternative approaches,
do check out the articles
linked in the description below.
JENNY BROWN: And if
you're hungry for more,
be sure to like, subscribe,
and catch up on all the ways
you can get cooking with Cloud.
[MUSIC PLAYING]